david rigoulet roze merci d'être avec
nous en direct sur rt france alors on se
souvient la signature d'un accord de
paix fin février entre les américains et
les talibans avaient suscité beaucoup
d'espoir pour un afghanistan apaisé est
cette matinée meurtrière métal fin
finalement à cet espoir
il faut bien dissocier les deux des deux
a fait elle une part active dans le
l'accord définit le 29 février à doha
entre les représentants talibans les
états unis prévoyant un retrait
programmé des états unis jusque
notamment avec une étape à l'été
prochain
et puis il y avait une clause qui
effectivement impliqué des négociations
adrar gagnent entre gouvernement et les
talibans en deuxième étape et notamment
il y avait un volet la libération par
anticipée d'un certain nombre de
prisonniers
ces 5000 taliban d'un côté et puis un
millier de soldats des forces
gouvernementales de l'osce a achoppé
notamment sur cette question là début
avril
manifestement ça a pris du retard parce
que il y avait un problème sur notamment
les les commandants talibans qui étaient
susceptibles de pouvoir être libéré
et puis la situation avec le colis de
favoriser le chaos incontestablement
dont profite que des ch
mais on peut noter que les talibans ont
nié toute participation ont donné lundi
l'attentât qui ne veut pas dire que vous
n'avez pas en lancer leur activité
puisqu'il ya près de trois cents 300
offensive qui avait défait que c'est
mort dernièrement donc compté plus de
mer- le mental mais en tout cas
effectivement par rapport à des c'est
une spécificité dans le katanga
l'histoire et qui concerne d'ailleurs
les centres urbains et anciennement et
on peut noter que les relations entre
neige et d'aliments de sont loin d'être
excellent alors vous le désir les
talibans ont nié tout rôle dans
l'attentât
ce que ne semblent pas croire le
président afghan a sera gagnée puisque
il a annoncé que les forces afghanes
passerait d'un mode défensif à un mode
actif pourquoi une décision si radicale
malgré le démenti des talibans oui alors
mal pour p&o a pris note du démenti dès
d'aliments et
c'était une manière de ne pas couper de
ne pas couper les ponts par rapport au
processus en cours
pour ce qui est du gouvernement le
gouvernant tu étais dans une pose
effectivement de 10 certaine manière
défense active puisque les talibans
avaient dit qu'ils renonçaient aux
attaques contre les forces étrangères
notamment américaines
mais que ça ne concernait pas
spécialement les forces gouvernementales
puisqu'ils ont toujours considéré que le
gouvernement et qu'un violent fantoche
et donc ça avait multiplié petit vent il
avait multiplié les attaques contre les
forces gouvernementales
là aujourd'hui il se trouve que le
président achraf rami parle de relancer
les opérations contre l'ennemi
s'empresse-t-il et d'ailleurs s'il
s'agit des talibans ou de neige
parce qu'effectivement en l'occurrence
ce type d'attentât porte la marque de
neige beaucoup plus que des aliments qui
ne veut pas dire que la situation était
sur le terrain à l'est d'el loin de là
mais donc il ya didier entretient la
confusion effectivement est un parasite
le bon déroulé et des étapes qui avait
été programmé par l'accord du 22 février
alors pour conclure la pandémie du
comité 19 finalement à beaucoup
détourner les regards des conflits comme
celui en afghanistan
est-ce que néanmoins une montée des
violences était perceptible ces derniers
jours ces derniers mois alors elle était
elle était certes il ya le rapport de
l'onu dutil est de fin avril 2020 qui
faisait un bilan sur l'année 2019 et qui
prenait acte du fait qu effectivement il
y avait une multiplication des depuis
début du mois de mars des opérations
actives de la part des talibans et que
ça ne favorisait pas effectivement la
poursuite du processus
donc c'était cette musique à sion dès
attaques qui effectivement est d aider
noter et c'est évidemment sa rentrée
dans les difficultés des négociations a
travaillé notamment avec le président al
ashraf ghani qui s'était retrouvée de
toute façon un peu marginalisé par le
processus entre direct entre les
américains et d'aliments c'est le reflet
de la confusion et du chaos qui prévaut
en irak en parle on l'a béni stands et
qui évidemment est une opportunité tour
pour
des ch dont une grande partie des formes
dyer avait été réduite par les talibans
m mais qui compte encore plusieurs
centaines de personnes et ce sont eux
qui perpètrent les attentats notamment
les villes à destination principalement
d'été de la communauté hazara notamment
un câble merci beaucoup david rigoulet
roze d'avoir répondu à nos questions je
rappelle que vous êtes chercheur à
l'ifan et l'iris est également rédacteur
en chef de la revue orient stratégique